the game is called
who said that
[Music]
so
each of you will pull a card and you
will read
the statement on the card whoever has
the card it's up to them to try to
figure out who said that then they will
guess and if they get it wrong we'll go
okay
who actually said it
that person will then take the floor and
say
why they said it and to home where they
speak i love this kid it's so close okay
who wants to go first i'll go cynthia
wants to go all right all right
here we go
i've tried for years to be able to trust
but what girlfriend calls up your
fiance's ex-girlfriends asking for
information
she should focus more on
her life than on my life
why don't you get a life for yourself
i may need some help
my guess
is
that
ramona said it to william
anyone want to come to this
it's the la show
i know i i think i think
[Music]
she only met him for three months and he
sent
beautiful cartier braces to all three of
his girlfriends besides her and i go
this is not good
you know what he married her that's
right
it's not whether or not tom gifted a
girl something the point is that ramona
called to try to dig up information
about tom to hurt me
in retrospect was ramona wrong about tom
no
but it was wrong to do what she did guys
are dogs like my brother was a dog until
he met melissa
well this guy was a dog even when he
married her okay
she's not wrong
but who digs like that
you shouldn't did that but you shouldn't
do that here's three other girls and
when she met him no no no no no no no no
we're not gonna do that no no ma'am no
we're not doing that i am a girl's girl
and i'll protect any one of you
no you're not
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
wait a second what did you just say
what did you just say i don't know i
just said you just said that
you went to bed with him the first night
you met him that's right and that's my
prerogative but is it for you to kiss
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to me that's not a friend i don't play
like that you know there's certain
boundaries you don't cross and when you
do
sleep with the horse's head no again i'm
kidding i'm kidding let me ask you a
question how many times have you had sex
with people on the first date never oh
my gosh so now you're holding up
i want to do that i want to be like hi
because i'm trying to say i want to be
like
i want to play sexuality
ramona loves to throw out little jabs
and then wants everything to be okay and
laugh it off
no you're leaving behind a trail of hurt
feelings
she's saying she's saying because she
wants to be like you raise your
sexuality
[Music]
do you think you are ramona don't talk
to me like that you call me a [ __ ] the
first time that we met yeah now you're
trying to come to me on my boat do you
want your ass thrown over the water
throw
[Music]
theresa did she insult you yes she did
cynthia did she insult you
let me get back to you okay
she insulted me keep it moving because
what you're not gonna do is disrespect
me
you're putting your fingers i'm pointing
my fingers
extremely disrespectful you're not going
to do that to me
look at me well we're not going to touch
each other
can you can go from zero to 100 very
quickly i don't think kenya needs to go
as far as she goes
i've only seen this sweet side of kenya
so now i'm starting to see the side that
people kind of warned me about i don't
know what you have heard about me but
everything is true [ __ ]
in the island
[Music]
are you ready
feel it can you feel it